foreign
participants have joined and those of
and those of you who have just joined uh
hello everyone uh we'll be starting with
the webinar in just a few more minutes
and meanwhile we are waiting it would be
great if you could introduce yourself in
the chat box you can introduce yourself
with your educational background and
research interest few of the
participants who joined initially they
have already introduced themselves that
they're from zoology background from
bioinformatics backgrounds from
microbiology background I'm curious to
know about the rest of you guys as well
please let me know in the chat
all right so meanwhile the participants
are introducing themselves in the chat
box I'm just going to start with the
today's webinar so hello everyone a very
warm greeting to one and all my name is
I would like to welcome you all for a
Hands-On webinar on chem informatics for
biomedical drug Discovery program for
those of you who are joining us for the
very first time the program is designed
for beginners and students who are eager
to learn about the fascinating field of
computational structure biology and chem
informatics and in today's webinar we
are joined by Dr puneet kakar mentor of
the chem informatics program who will
cover topics on scientific search
methods and organizing literature data
as a part of beginning research work
explain what chem informatics is and
highlight the latest trends in the field
as well as answer some of the queries
that the participants might be having of
the program curriculum
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program
we are a USBS bioinformatics company who
is working with multiple academic and
Commercial collaborators to develop easy
to use analytical tools and our mission
is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
and as a part of the program students
will have access to the omic's logic
training that has been completed by over
24 000 participants from 187 countries
in over 300 workshops and this training
has been completed in six different
specialization tracks that includes
oncology infectious diseases Precision
medicine Neuroscience data science for
biomedical data
and as a part of the program students
will also have access to the omecologic
resources which takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear path of the
Bloom's taxonomy pyramid and no matter
what the users initial experience with
bioinformatics is omix logic is a useful
tool for gaining a baseline knowledge of
the theory behind bioinformatics
analysis of large data sets and
introduction to basic coding languages
like R and python or even beginning a
data analysis project
and this also comes with an access to
the warming strategic courses which
include courses on by informatics
Precision medicine multiomics that makes
use of genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics and apigenomics data
science that includes bioinformatics
using RN python as well as chem
informatics and example projects of
different fields which you could learn
from and replicate for your research
work
users will also be given directions to
access the T bioinfo platform for
bioinformatic processing and Analysis of
data the platform includes demo
pipelines as well as data management and
Analysis Cloud infrastructure to run the
bioinformatic pipelines and different
stages of analysis are performed on
different sections on this multiomics
platform so now to view the various
courses and example projects let us
first sign up on the omics logic learn
portal
so for signing up I am sharing the link
in the chat box for the participants
so please visit the link and I'll walk
you through on how you can sign up since
I can see that a lot of the participants
responded that they are joining the
webinar for the very first time so I'll
walk you through a brief demo on how you
can sign up so for those participants
who have just joined the webinar please
click on the create an account option
that you see here and to create an
account you can enter a name email ID
and a password or you also have the
option to sign up using any of your
social media accounts this could be your
Google Facebook account Apple account
GitHub account or even Twitter and also
few of the participants have already
joined the previous webinar so for those
they can just simply click on the login
now option and sign on the portal so
I'll pause for a couple of seconds for
the participants to sign up once you
have signed up please put a yes in the
chat box and those of you who already
have an account on the portal please put
it done so that I know that everyone has
signed up and once you have done I'll
walk you through the various courses and
example projects that are there on the
portal
okay roof will say is done what about
rest of you guys
if you're facing any technical issues
you can let us know in the chat box as
well and our team will be happy to guide
you
foreign
okay perfect I can see that participants
are signing up thank you so much for
your responses all right so meanwhile
I'm just going to uh sign in so the
participants can uh sign a sign up along
so for those of you who have just signed
up you can see that the very first
interface that you see once you sign up
is this uh various display of the
courses that are there so once you
scroll down you will see a search bar
that says uh looking for a specific
course so in this search bar you can
enter the keyword that you're interested
so let's say you're interested in
informatics so that will show you the
courses that are related to the chem
informatics and you can also browse
through and navigate various other
keywords um and look at the various
courses that are there on the portal
based on the keyword
so let us say you're interested in
machine learning you can simply enter
the keyword and that will show you the
various courses and example projects
that makes use of machine learning so
you can navigate through and
explore at your own piece now
um we have to set up your account as
well so for that just click on the tab
that says welcome back with your email
ID
so once you click on this you'll be able
to see your account settings here when
you go to the icon that says profile you
will be able to edit all of the options
so one of the very first important
features that you need to have update is
your profile image so for that you can
simply click on the select file to
upload and upload an image from your
local system and you also need to make
sure that your name has to be in proper
capitalization
and also you have the option to link
your social media handles so in my case
I have linked my LinkedIn account and my
work ID and finally another last
important feature that you need to
update is your bio so here in my bio I
have mentioned my educational background
and my research interest so the
participants can set up your profile uh
similarly and you will also see the
various tabs that are there on the
portal so under the activity tab the
program mentor and the community manager
will be tracking your learning progress
and under the courses tab the courses
that you are currently completing will
be displayed finally after the
completion of a project and once it is
published on the portal your project
will be displayed under the projects tab
and once you enroll for any of the
programs for instance the
cheminformatics program you'll be able
to track your program progress under the
programs tab finally after the
completion of your coursework and
required assignments you will be able to
receive the certificates under the
certificate step so that was all about
navigating through the portal
so let me see
um
no one has any queries uh and I can say
that a lot of them have signed up so if
you are facing any technical issues or
have any queries please feel free to
share it in the chat but for now let us
move on to the next
um Hands-On session for today's webinar
for that I would like to pass on the
stage to the program Mentor Dr puneet
Kaka who is a drug Discovery scientist
and Industry analytics manager at
Accenture to over to yourself
thank you very much sonalika I just
wanted to check if you are able to hear
me properly
yes you're perfectly Audible
okay
thanks thank you very much hello
everyone
um so let me share my screen I have a
small presentation but
a significant amount of and so on
and we can discuss this
is called Let me show my
presentation here
is there let me share my screen
and it should be coming to you now yes
this screen yes
yes okay
let me know if you are able to see my
screen
yes sir we can see your screen oh okay
this is very good thank you
so let me connect this to
[Music]
just want to see how we can
make this one down I don't know
okay
I just wanted to bring the
laser here but um I'm seeing this screen
by anyway just don't worry about it so
today's session will be
sorry
today's session will be based on the uh
the research that we begin with this
search important aspects of any research
and I believe since you are attending
this specific Workshop in webinar you
are some Fair have a scientific
curiosity you have some hypothesis in
mind you have a great interest to learn
new things in the area of Life Sciences
cheminformatics chemistry or maybe in a
similar Allied areas as well
so whenever you are starting or
beginning your journey in the in in this
area of research the first and the
foremost thing that is required to do
Hands-On is to search
extensively search
repeatedly search again and again such
every day search to make your knowledge
up to date search to have your self
acquainted well enough with the latest
friends in technology search
sufficiently so that you you understand
whatever is already has been done in the
in the field of your interest or not so
begin your research with the search is
something which is very beginning of
your assignment that you should always
be comfortable bed
but unfortunately many times when we
begin our journey of research at a very
late stage we understand how to do a
better search
how we can manage our search results
what are the key aspects we should
always consider while we are searching
our
um research our topic what is the best
ideal way what is the best scenario
um what is the right set of tools and
Technique we should use what is the
right search engine we should use what
is the right database we should search
and rely on
how we can get the PDFs how we can get
the full text there's so many things
around
just a search
and search being so important is a very
much neglected in the initial phase and
that's why it causes a lot of problems
to the research students
this session is dedicated
some part of the search how you how you
can make your research Journey more
comfortable more confident more
streamlined more manageable
in in in your area
with the right set of
knowledge in place
so I have a very
small presentation which will cover
couple of things
one is why search is so important
second we'll discuss about what are the
two major key platforms or highly used
platforms from biomedical literature
search when I say biomedical it doesn't
mean that
the chemistry is not involved chemistry
for biology is also involved here
drug Discovery is for the life sciences
it's connected closely so you will find
those articles also in those two
platforms though they are very well
known to you
but there are many interesting things
you should always consider while
searching or using these two platforms
manage search results you can get the
search
very easily
but it's not just a search or the
keyword that you should use it's it's
the story
begins once you get the results if you
get thousands of Articles as a search
results how many would you read how
would you bucket them into different
categories how you can focus yourself
so that a small amount of yet very
powerful article should not miss from
your eyes
how you can manage those things
so managing the search results is
equally and I believe is more important
than just search
other things maybe you have five
different articles that are so important
for your knowledge to complete your PhD
work or maybe a small Project work with
a very fundamental articles
but how would you land up to those and
how would you keep those articles
ensuring that during you should read
them all you should flag them
sufficiently at a right place so that
whenever you need them you can get those
articles
and you can ensure that you can cite
them in your in your thesis
performing a systematic reviews it's a
different area but it's not very well
known to people
and especially in the clinical trials
data if you are looking for
or doing for a systematic review a
review of the clinical trial studies
results that have been done in the past
what is the right right method to do
that it's not just collecting bunch of
article
and
and just start reporting them no it's
it's a different method
a it's it's a different way of you know
accumulating the research in a in a way
that way that it should only make a lot
of sense in the in the in the final
conclusion that you made
so it's just not
citing the people citing the article and
telling their opinion you need to come
up your opinion as well in your in the
reviews article it's like you are
reading a lot of Articles and then
saying okay our understanding is like
this this is what we observe this is how
our point of view should uh our this is
how we think our point of view is like
this
okay some conclusion has to be made and
you can make conclusion only if you are
comparing the studies fairly in an
unbiased fashion
right so performing a systematic reviews
and certainly some key considerations
that you should always keep in mind
may be very useful to you
um in the whole journey of your research
let me know if you have any questions so
far
if you have some questions keep writing
on the chat so that at the end we can
take them
but I think we can start uh for the
interesting things
why search is so important
it's you are doing research not just
because you need a degree
the major or more important aspect of
the research is you want to contribute
something
whatever you are taking as a knowledge
from literature search is somebody else
contribution in that field
that is if you are doing a research it
is your accountable you are accountable
and in a very honest and fair fashion
you should feel yourself responsible
that you need to contribute in the
enhancement and enrichment of the
scientific research
it means that your output of the
research should be such that
it should progress
the knowledge it should enhance the
knowledge of scientific research
it should have some contribution
no matter big or small but it should it
should not be duplicated it should not
it should not
replicate the same stuff in a different
wordings possibly that is also part of
research maybe people who have reported
so far for a topic which is very
difficult for other people to understand
and your research is to make them simple
so that everybody can understand that's
also fine but that's a big contribution
that's a great contribution I believe so
consider that whatever you are doing in
your research you are
the owner of that work and you deliver
that work in the most effective way
that's your responsibility
right so search will help you to do that
how you will search the things which are
already done in the past you will ensure
that what you are thinking to do in your
research has not been done so far
or maybe has not done that way uh yet it
means that you need to design your study
in a way that you should further
add on add on the information which has
already been done you take that
information
bring your experiments in picture and
then bring the knowledge
add on the knowledge
hmm
Point number two it has been formulating
a reset question and planning and
planning this study
when you are reviewing the literature
which has been done the past extensively
was extensively searching those things
it will also help you to formulate what
has been already done
and that should not be repeated in your
experiment or if it is repeated there
should be a benchmark that should meet
the criteria which should be as per at
par with the scientific guidelines
so whenever whenever you are planning
something you need to ensure that this
exact thing should not be done earlier
and this is possible once you keep on
learning and reading what has been
already done in the past and that is
feasible once you start doing a thorough
searching
extensive searching there should not be
anything which is unturned so fast so
that you can ensure that whatever you
are thinking is in the right direction
meets the scientific requirements and
there is a there is a need in the
scientific domain that this knowledge
has to be has to come into the picture
right
Point number three
it improves the quality of research
because you are adding a new knowledge
and in the way that has to be accepted
by the scientific community means your
protocols
it improves the quality of research if
it improves the quality of research you
get the benefit of it right you feel
more confident about it your research
gets appreciated around the world people
start citing your articles citing your
Publications scientific people invite
you for the
uh for the dogs and for the uh
discussions
you also possibly file the patents and
move your
output or scientific scientific outcomes
to a product a product can help the
mankind it can improve the patient's
life so there are so many things when
you genuinely do the research work right
it is possible only if you meet all the
criterias of
um scientific research
search reading
reviewing you know understanding the
domain
formulating the right questions
putting down your hypothesis doing the
right set of experiments
generating the results which are
acceptable to the scientific Community
adopting the right set of protocols it's
all it's like a very well connected
things
so it improves the quality of research
coin number four it significantly
enhances your subject matter expertise
so if you start reading the Articles uh
from the
from the uh
previous authors who have been who have
been doing that when you work in that
area
you will certainly
um
uh
become a subject matter expert because
you also have a very in-depth
understanding of your work so that also
pays at a later stage in your career
and people recognize you because of your
knowledge in that area
so it will help you
Point number five it five introduces you
with the latest trends in technique
that's important you may be thinking to
design your experiment
in a very traditional way or maybe
because you have studied that protocol
method in your
in your graduation or post graduation
program
but when you are doing a research 45 in
the next five years time
with the you need to ensure that
the right
Trends and techniques in that area
that can really speed up accelerate your
findings with a more confidence
and whatever you were thinking to do in
a three years five years time you can
actually do in a in in just one year
time with more accuracy
for example
prediction of a three-dimensional
structure of the protein
you were thinking you will do some MD
simulations you will do some homology
based prediction have initial based
predictions and do that
but since machine learning has come into
picture
maybe you find that whatever you are
thinking to do by yourself it's already
there in the in the databases
and it is wide accepted
maybe you can use that one no need to
build from scratch and do the further
analysis of maybe
designing new molecules for the exercise
which were not previously in the in the
purview of your research interest or
research work very funny
so once you understand the latest tools
and techniques and trends
it helps you to
redefine your area into the research and
you can really run fast
more accurate
um more productive more efficient
for for the area of your interest so
keep in mind that these things are
possible once you do a thorough due
diligence
in in the in the search
important point is that
whenever you
search for something you find hundreds
of Articles maybe thousands of articles
now it's not possible for a human being
to read those thousands of article in a
short amount of time because once you
complete thousand by the time there are
another set of thousand comes into the
library
it is important that you need certain
smart methods
to your Niche area
that you can effectively read them
understand them in a short amount of
time
and
you become expert in that area
sooner as possible
so you need right set of tools and
techniques
I hope you understand why search is so
important and you will certainly
recognize this as an important aspect
whenever you do any any uh begin any
research work assigned to you
in your in your program
keep writing the questions that you have
in mind maybe we'll come back and check
those
let me go to the second one
there are two very key and important
platforms there could be other
proprietary
um I would say platform as well
but to me publicly available these two
are the best one for biomedical
literature search
one is PubMed and second is Google
Scholar
Fair PubMed is highly focused on
biomedical literature research on the
other side the Google Scholar is
something which can search anything
if it is a mathematics paper if it is a
Applied Mathematics on chemical Sciences
biological sciences if you are looking
at the psychology paper which is done on
any
Behavioral Studies on your disease area
or so
no matter what is Google Scholar is much
wider Google Scholar also provides
search results from accessory articles
and
um review pages from websites
for example White Pages maybe from
literature which are patent patent
documents right those articles are also
come into Google Scholar with the
mention of the number of citations there
PubMed on the other hand has a very
systematic controlled index article
articles which provide some historical
Trends on the term results the number of
their number of outputs quantity the
hits are very kind of accurate in that
sense
and you can filter the article by
reviews by year and so on
Google Scholar
um is something which
which uses a parent Google Google search
which is absolutely uh
um the grade absolutely great
so therefore the search quality you can
say the ontology of the search is really
really good
nonetheless both are I use both of them
I recommend both of them because
um you can find
certain differences in the outcome of
these search results
permit
and permit Center another another site
on the ncbi
is since the permit Center is dedicated
for the full text articles
um
Google Scholar has the option that if
the article is available in any PDF form
uh anywhere on the search results so
that's added Advantage there however
permit does not link all the possible
ways where for example University
website where the article is available
free of course so that's a limitation on
the side another limitation from permit
is the number of citations for the
article so it becomes little biased in a
way that you pick always the article
with the high citation will come to that
point
but but not always true that the highly
cited one is the best one
so maybe I can go quickly to show both
of the search results from Google
Scholar and pubmit
so I will open the edge here so I have
this
um
I have this one
PubMed available here so in case I
wanted to see the results for say
uh Alzheimer's
as I must disease so it also provides
you the suggestions which is fine as I'm
a disease you get desserts you see how
many results are there 40 000 plus
results are there
well it's very difficult for someone to
read 40 000 articles in in a for a small
space
on the left hand side you see couple of
filters option
um the status success Alzheimer's
disease you can see then initially
started around 1975 article has started
coming in and they are rapidly
increasing or consistently increasing
year on year till 2023 we have quite a
significant number of articles
um other than that you can filter them
by a straight full text full text free
full text
um some Associated supplementary data
whether they are both clinical trial
data reported meta-analysis supported
some clinical trial data is reported Etc
um also you can see from last one year
last five years ten years data supported
other options include the save these
searches for example I will show you why
this is so important but saving is
important email is important you want to
send these results somewhere
um or save it in a clipboard my
bibliography collections also you can do
another important thing is you can click
create alert which is important for
example I want to create alert and I can
choose the frequency D format Etc you
can save it is I will show you when this
is very important it's important point
of discussion in my slide
and you can also have a display option
where
you can say I need a summary I need a
abstract base
um
show me website based things so for
example
article title authors affiliations IDs
and then you have the abstract reported
etc etc other informations are also
reported here
so this is the uh a general description
of the PubMed based search you can
narrow down the search for example
adding more and more terms for example
Alzheimer's disease biomarkers
so initially we were having 40 000
articles now we will have 4 000 articles
just 10 percent of it and then we can
say
machine learning for example machine
learning
I want to I wanted to know the Articles
which have
machine learning term biomarker term and
I'm a disaster
and see there are 65 articles so as you
increases the area uh focused area it
becomes reducing the number of Articles
and whether they are making sales or not
you see as I have a disease drug
development Pipeline and somewhere they
have mentioned about in the Articles so
it means that whenever you are searching
like this it is looking all over the
article place where these terms are
present
if you see as I'm applied a machine
learning Alzheimer's disease research or
mix emerging and clinical data which is
also fine so if you want to do the same
search with Google Scholar so let me go
to this caller
here's the Google Scholar
okay and I can search it here
so you see with this term we have 27 000
results
and you see the PDF options are also
given somewhere
wherever the article is available you
also see the difference that's cited by
is given number of times this article
has been cited so it's a good Merit to
see whether the article is
sufficiently read by the others and
cited by this is one of the criterias of
selecting the articles
for your quick you know quick uh review
and such you have the filter by this and
you say by default it is not included or
patents are excluded in the search if
you include the patents then this 27 000
will be become 28 000 or around 29 000
research
so that's little bit of difference here
but very fundamental difference of
course the top 10 articles here may not
be top 10 certainly not the top 10
articles there because the criteria of
search is completely different I believe
but I may be wrong here for some
articles maybe you find both the places
at the top top 10 or so but a huge
difference right 65 articles and you see
77 500 article and it becomes even more
uh focused that's a good thing you need
less article but high quality articles
if you do with the advanced search when
you go to the advanced search you say I
need machine learn all the terms should
be written
all the terms should be written in the
title let me see if if it produces any
results or not let me see
opqrs title
let me see if it produces any result
16 articles
so machine learning Alzheimer disease
[Music]
um
I believe biomarker is taking title and
abstract
so you have biomarker disease
Alzheimer's disease machine learning is
there in the title so this is how you
can really focus on the
on the other so what I can do I can
download this 16 articles
in in a very specific format called save
all results and I will say permit
permit method
so PubMed output file will be created
for all the 16 users let me do this
I am doing intentionally will tell you
why but let me go to the presentation
again
all right
so this is code
permit Google Scholar there are certain
differences
both are good ways to search
and interesting
now you get the results what will you do
with those results
you will will save those results
somewhere
in the
in your hard hard drive
um
if you are saving those results or PDF
in some folders how would you
um how would you recall them
whenever you need them while writing the
publication
believe me it's not that simple
you will really scratch your head if
if you are doing the literature
management that way
folders and subfolders which article how
you read how you identify
which articles to site where
every time if you are doing this way of
management every time you need to write
a single paragraph you will search 10
times for The Articles to cite is not
absolutely a good three a best way the
right way to manage your search results
for the literature search
so because there was a problem
there was a solution also created for it
people have created some specialized
software for bibliographic management
and these are called kind of reference
management or reference manager
softwares
some are
I would say many of them are
commercially available
some of them are freely available but
with a very limited
um I would say capacity you can you can
only search 19 manage 99 articles or so
much of article you need this much you
need some amount to pay after that oh so
many terms and conditions
and they are little bit expensive
softwares for a student or four
on the other hand
with the God grace we have a software
which is freely available
open source and does exactly the same
right job
here we are presenting two
two very well known softwares in these
two disciplines two different
uh
layers one is endnote
highly used very powerful
but paid
on the right side right hand side you
have a zotero which is freely available
reference manager does exactly the same
job
in a very efficient way
completely free of cost if you are using
a cloud you may need to pay for after
certain
amount of storage that is required but
to some extent it is free Standalone
version is free
so I will come to that point
I do not have the endnote with me but
zotero I have installed for this
specific presentation
and I will show you how you can manage
your search results
let me go here
so I installed zotero by going to the
website
hello if it types of Tarot
you will see your personal research
assistant zotero is free open source
reference management software
very good you have
very bold and clear line easy a tool
helps to organize annotate site share
research
um you can download it available for Mac
Windows Linux and iOS this is great
a very very user friendly software no
limitations on the Standalone version
can be connected to Cloud
no worries about the data loss Etc
so it's very good so I have this zotero
in case
and what I will do I will go to
let me
yeah let me go to this one
so what you see here on the left hand
side is a hierarchy of certain options
that how you can manage your library you
can rename them you can do a lot of
stuff here folder and folders subfolders
but they are visible to you and it
really like fashion
you have on top is a mini menu buttons
and some quick options
on the right hand side is called the
information section about a article that
you have selected in the center pane the
center pane is just provides a list of
the titles and Associated information
that you want to see you can customize
to the at some extent and
you can do that
what you need to do you can need to
bring the Articles into this platform
now bringing the Articles can be done in
multiple ways one is either you can
create manually
second is
you can set in second thing is you can
you can
search the results uh using PubMed or
Google Scholar and save that file and
you can bring it here
and third thing is you can do use the
plugin which is also available with this
Edge
I believe that's available here
some plug-in option that I
I see zotero connector is available so
that
can be also be used
so what is the most preferred way that I
am going to show it to you the way I
have done the search for Alzheimer's
disease biomarkers and machine learning
what I did is basically I saved the
results all the results how many 19
articles
in a permit format and save the files so
um I will go to the zotero I will say
I let me delete this one
delete collection and items
so that we can have a fresh
now with this one uh I will go to file
import
and I will say I need to import this
file
from my download which is permit
assignment set and let me copy files to
zotero storage folder
which is fine
and it is importing
you see all the
articles are now available now 16
articles are available here
how many were there
16 articles were there as well
not 19 by 16. so I have the 16 articles
here with the titles reported here and
in the information pane you can see a
lot of information given all the authors
abstract Etc with volume issues page
number this and this this is this this
is this if you want to add some of the
information that you have you can always
do that it will be saved here and since
I connected zotero with the free storage
Cloud that there provides it is syncing
my
my library here now what I want is since
this is for machine learning in
biomarker I can rename this
sorry to interrupt yourself the screen
is not moving
yes it's not moving okay
let me reshare it
um
okay
we were able to see until you were
showing the 16 results
are you able to see it now
yes so we can see a list of the research
papers
uh with the zotero yes sir in this hotel
okay sorry uh so I was saying this
zotero is a platform where you can
you can see this the hierarchical
hierarchical arrangement of the
um list of items you have menu returns
you have the toolbar options you have
the information pane here in the center
you will see the list so what I did I
can read through the same thing here I
can delete the collection in the item
again
go to the file import I believe you can
see all these things now
and I'm download I have downloaded this
file
and doing this one copy to the sparrow
and next
so this finishes my import of all the
Articles here you see this is syncing to
my zotero drive which is provided free
of course to me
now since these articles are very much
very much of the machine learning side I
would say machine learning
I can rename them I can drag and drop it
here so that they become the part one
summer
this is how I do that this is a
hierarchy same way you can do a lot of
other folders creation for example here
you can do the folder creation you can
say for cancer
and you can have the cancer less like
exam you have cancer and different
different types of cancer for example I
can say as new sub collection see and
that's it
so cancer within pancreatic cancer you
can have again new soft collections
that is all possible and very very
manageable
now if I go to uh the machine learning
articles if I click on any of the
articles I see a lot of information
about the general articles types uh the
abstract the authors
the other information so in case you
have other information you can certainly
edit it keep it saved and it will
automatically save each article is also
tagged with some of the
um
keywords I would say tags for that but
just in case you want to add a new tag
you can go to the tags and add a new tag
okay for example if this article is
important to you and you want to say
that a must read article you can say you
can add a note here saying that okay
notice here is important
those side
pieces
and you can just do this and this is all
done
now
um if you go to the um
the other section of this so this is
available here you can always do
information text and if you want to do
some related article that also you can
search the related article and make the
tag one of the important aspect is that
I want to know what are the free
articles available here so what I will
do I will just to control a here to
select everything right click here
and find available PDF so very cool
feature
uh it will try its best to see if the
full text are available
and just not available
it will also add the PDF right after
your article
isn't a cool thing you think it's a very
cool thing I believe it's not that it's
it's takes a lot of pain to get all
those things in just few clicks
so it is searching making and
identifying particles wherever the full
PDF is available
um
and you will get it right there another
cool feature here is you can double
click on this one and go to that article
directly just in case you want to read
more about it and see more of the
information just in case you want it
that is already there
right so 27 euros
expensive one
okay so that's another cool feature of
set arrow and it's really helps you
another point of uh
using this one is not just managing this
Library
but also to cite article while you are
writing your manuscript now that's a
very important aspect
for this
how would you do that citation
let me show it to you I will go to Ms
word let me see yes
this is the MS word
okay
um and I want to cite some article so
you see once you install the zotero you
will see the zotero option available in
Microsoft Word by default now what you
need to do is
[Music]
um
you want to write a review article in
saying uh some lines are like that
um
machine learning
significantly
contributed
in the
it's only or in the identification in
the identification
and markers or say
about this
biomarkers
or
for example this is one of your lines in
the article
and you are writing for say Journal of
care
medicine chemistry also so you what you
need to do is do this click here add
edit citation
and look for your
general medicine chemistry for example
here it was not there by default I added
with the managed Styles you go to the
main style and look for the Articles
from there
it's a terrified and you can add this
one here okay so once you add it you
will see that is available
now if I go to the um
add text here I can go to channel of
medicine chemistry gmatcam I will say
Okay I want to cite an article as soon
as you just click add the zotero option
will available can someone confirm me if
you are able to see my screen with this
zotero search option on the Microsoft
Word
yes sir we can see a red color
rectangular box yes perfect now what I
will do I will search for my library
everything is already there
so I will search for
let me see if there is Noble biomarker
yes
my marker is there okay for example I
want to
decide
uh from the Bible okay say oh make space
this one I want to slide so this one is
I have added I just wanted to add one
article if you want to add again you can
start searching it for example like this
worker you can add another article but I
am not doing it this moment and I just
click enter here
you see one has been added but where is
the article so if you want to
add the article you just say
[Music]
um
add bibliography
so your first article has been added
exactly in the format of what general or
mental chemistry accepts in the
Publications
there's one thing if you want to change
the
document in a different way you just
click on the different method document
preferences select a different method
and you are just okay you just need to
say okay and that's it everything will
be done for you so
this is how you can cite your article in
in your manuscript and you can keep your
manuscript always ready to change
uh to a particular General
guidelines
okay this is how you can save it that's
fine you know everything
so this is how zotero
um
Works briefly and I think the search is
also completed you see one two three
four five
six seven article out of sixteens are
available in PDF form you can always go
and look at the PDF
very cool you have the PDF article
I wish I knew this during my PST time
but
I think
some of these cool features were already
there I use them very effectively but
some features are really really good
so uh that's briefly about the uh zotero
and managing your library you can do a
lot of bifurcation for example uh if
there is a deep learning let me know
there's no this for example is there any
diagnosis
so if there is a diagnosis
there is a diagnosis two articles are
there for diagnosis what I can do I can
create a subfolders in Alzheimer machine
learning and say
and I can create a diagnosis
these two articles I want to move them
or just copy them into diagnosis I will
have the diagnosis two articles and this
remain intact 16 items
so
um just in case you have multiple
articles you want to remove duplicates
within the same within the same then you
can certainly do the duplicate removal
and this way you can do a lot of good
stuff
um another thing is just in case you
want to add a an article uh by the
permit ID for example
okay info let me go to the info of this
article and see if there is a permit ID
so this is a permit ID let me see
and that hilli name is
let me go and search let's see if
this works I don't know if it takes the
oh this seems like it has already added
Azure mix biomarker two times now
and this is already added now
and let me see
if this is already done
foreign
let me see if there is any see the
duplicate article has come here and you
can now
uh
see both the Articles here
right so it is saying merge two items
because it has found that these are two
articles which are duplicated by some
combination of title IDs Etc you can say
yes merge to articles now you don't have
any duplicate article and this one will
be only one time reported here okay
very cool I believe you understand what
I'm saying but uh
this is how it is
good stuff
so on that part we have covered the
endnote and so tarot part now coming
into the systematic reviews when you are
doing a review of the specifically
clinical trial data or significantly a
similar potentially similar kind of data
reported in by means of literature there
are methods to do a systematic reviews
it's just not like finding uh last five
years article in
this is uh their full text availability
you are just doing the compilation and
reporting it
so it has a very systematic ways of
accumulating the data excluding the
Articles and then reporting it is called
prism a format and
the link for this publication is given
there I highly encourage you if you are
in the process of doing this or you have
some plans of doing a systematic review
look into this one the original article
image is like this which says
identification screening eligibility
what is included and generally it is how
General people are reporting this one in
a reformatted way but the ideal ideology
is exactly same
the method is exactly the same so they
say that how many articles you found in
the in the database is there any
additional source of data you combine
the Articles these many articles were
there after removing the duplicates
now you have screened the article basis
the requirement
so you screen all the Articles and you
have excluded the Articles because they
were not meeting the criteria
now eligibility is whether the
description required for the for the
review is matching the requirement what
are the articles are required so you are
saying you are excluding some of the
Articles here 103 and their breakup is
also domain because there was no clear
uh qualitative component let me zoom and
Define possible
um
I don't know how to assume it here uh
early phase screening prevention in
ineligible RCT
um random clinical trial uh population
ineligible phenomena of Interest
abstract only duplicate so all those
things will be excluded whatever is
remaining for qualitative research you
study 45 articles and you have made
conclusion on all 45 articles so this is
how you have to present your workflow
and then you do a meta-analysis called
quantitative
um synthesis of
the
the search and the analysis
now coming to the last section which is
which are set of key concentration I
think we are on the top of the heart but
I will take just another minute to
complete it that
uh while searching the article it's
important that citations is one of the
key criterias but not always because
there are some great articles maybe
unnoticed somehow because of the lack of
right keyword or maybe availability in
the full text or maybe somebody just not
recognize the Merit of that article
right
[Music]
and also maybe article is very new to be
cited heavily so those things are
considerable when you are searching the
uh searching the Articles and selecting
the articles for yours
references
you can prefer articles with good
illustration in simple English so that
you can understand them fully you can
imagine what they are saying sometimes
difficult and illustration really helps
a lot there so you can do you can do a
create Alert in Google and
and and permit use that functionality is
very important because it will keep you
up to date with the latest recent
articles coming coming uh or indexed in
those uh platforms so you will
understand them what is the latest going
on there
you can utilize Cloud sync wherever
possible for your future for your
research work because it will help you
to get free from possibility of hard
disk corruption
um broken hard disk or asset lost it it
it really helps you to keep your data
secure and really really helpful they
are they're very good services
use trusted freely available software so
trust it means sometimes the software
says it's free but if you see the terms
and condition they may be free for
certain number of Articles which is
absolutely a waste of time I believe
doing uh taking the taking the software
on trial
it's just for trial
you cannot do it for long term so just
stick to something which is freely
available if you if you can't afford the
license
or if you think that free enough freely
available is really a good enough one
for your particular case
so believe on that and just go ahead
citing original research is strongly
recommended rather than
um an article citing the original
article you need not to cite that
reference article you need to cite the
original article for your work and
explore programmatic methods for text
mining is also very important aspect I
would say
new and new methods are coming in
Knowledge Graph
and natural language processing of
finding the right article mining the
literature
um performing quantitative analysis on
the Articles what they are saying doing
making the relationships between the
entities as a very very good I believe
you should explore those possibilities
if you can do hence on on
on some of the Python packages which
requires some programmatic skills so
that you can really mine good number of
articles
and do a lot of analysis
so this is all that I have for you in
this particular webinar
I must thank you for your uh for your
patients listening to me uh all the time
here
till the end I hope you find the session
interesting and you have learned
something new useful for your research
best wishes for your scientific Journey
thank you very much
oh thank you so much sir so we do have a
few queries in the chat uh so the first
query is from Khadija she is asking
between two more articles there are many
citations should we read those in
details too
so is it like two articles have a lot of
variation the number of citations is
that the question
I'll repeat the question once more
between two more articles there are many
citation should we read those in details
too
I would say start with the abstract
wherever the Articles has the
as the
um the content which is relevant for
your work this should not be any
hesitation to look any other other
parameter if it is if this is covering
your topic of interest just go and read
them
thank you sir and we have another query
from mahanas is this program designed
specifically for research scientists
this particular
session I believe for the other
upcoming sessions they are holistically
covering right from the beginning to the
some level of Advance we understand that
the the the attendees are the
participants are from the varied
background they have some basic
understanding maybe no understanding or
they may be having some intermediate
understanding but there are certain
questions they always have in mind and
there may be common
so in short to answer your questions it
is covering right from the basic
to some level of intermediate
level
and for
undergrades grades graduates and post
graduates in for phds as well
all right thank you so much sir so now
I'd like to pass on the stage to shubham
who will be covering the program
registration and cost so over to you
show them
thank you sugary so hello everyone I am
shubham I am the business development
and marketing associate here at pan
biotech
so I'll be um briefing you about the
registration process for the program
coming from Michael Justice and I'm
sharing my screen
yes sugar we can see your screen
yeah all right so yeah uh so uh as you
can see uh this is the page uh for the
uh like we have program cam informatics
for biomedical drug discovery
so I'll share you the link of the page
so that you can go after after this
session
so what all you will basically learn
from this session is uh something uh
like 3D structures then qsar docking and
uh like the molecular Dynamics now as
you will scroll down uh you can see that
there is a program overview section in
this uh you will get us a summary of the
program that what all the topic civil
and Concepts you will be uh learning
like the uh I thought through screen
screening part then the talking as well
as how you can use these topics for
various research projects uh if from a
biotech background or a pharmaceutical
background along with you will get a
complete Mentor guidance program also
like mental guidance also
so uh as you'll scroll down a bit more
uh you can see that we have a
interactive calendar where some of the
dates are highlighted like 26 28 and 29
so today and on the right side you can
see that uh we have uh let's see what
are topics we will be covering in those
particular dates so today on 26th Jan we
had the Hands-On Workshop but and your
next session will be day after tomorrow
that is on 28th and you will be learning
about the computational structure
biology some of the topics like protein
structures and all some databases also
so uh yes now uh comment on more you
will see that we have three different
tenures for this program one is 45 days
60 days and 90 days
so the resources for this program uh the
common resources for all the three
tenures is you will get the online
tutorial uh like the complete access of
the homies logic loan platform where you
will get the uh tutorial part and as
well as the project examples also and
you will get the coding sessions hands
and coding sessions also will be there
and by chance if you miss any of these
sessions then we will provide you with
the session recording also then online
mentor and technical support will be
provided and of course after the
completion you will get a certificate
now the difference uh in these tenuries
like you can see for the 60 days tenure
you have uh three extra things or the
three extra uh
opportunities that is your you will get
a one-on-one Mentor session and you can
draft your research proposal also and
after that you can like showcase your
research proposal or the uh your
research project work as a poster from
the poster presentation in various
International symposiums
and for the 90 days along with the
mentor session you will get an ample
amount of time to work on your research
project and get it published in the peer
review journal so this uh is the golden
opportunity for the 90 days part
now coming to the pricing part as you
can see uh See like the pricing we have
mentioned is in USD and for 45 days it
is uh 150 dollars and for 60 days it is
and for the 90 days it is uh 450 dollars
so uh like some if someone is from India
I'll show you in that Ina also so you
can see that there is a drop down above
so you just simply have to click on that
drop down and select the currency based
on your location so in INR you will find
that for 45 days it is 75
and for 60 it is uh nine triple nine and
for 90 days it is 14 triple nine and for
African communities they can also view
the amount like in nine naira so here
are the pricings for for our African
Community
now how to proceed with the um like
enrollment part of the recession part so
let's say I'm interested for the 90 days
part so I just simply have to click on
buy now
and
yeah it is you know
[Music]
yeah you will see this uh checkout page
then you can fill up your user details
and select the check box and you can
select the payment method you can go for
this type of the PayPal method and if
you are like we have alternative methods
also like bank transfer credit card uh
or debit card
so uh you can opt for that one also
so this all was for the registration
part
so over to you sugar or if you have any
queries uh please feel free
to yes thank you sugary
[Music]
thank you and for
eign
uh yeah it was just uh like telling you
about to share the marketing at all the
content details which we have already
done
uh so I have a uh I've got a query from
Ankita she's asking if I take monthly
subscription may I get access to all the
courses of homing's logic along with
certifications
yeah of course like if uh you will and
like for monthly subscription we have
and in that you will get the complete
access of the learn portal but uh for
the mentor guidance and one-on-one
session you have to uh opt for the
tenures which we have like for 60 or for
the 90 days but yes if you want to
enroll for the monthly subscription you
can do that so you can uh like mail uh
like just message me your email ID we
can like be in contact with you for the
monthly part description part
foreign
this is just a note for the participants
those who are interested in receiving
the webinar recording insights and
details for enrolling in the program uh
kindly share your email ID so that we
can share the details regarding program
curriculum and scholarship uh options
that we have for the participants and in
the chat box I've also
um shared the email ID and the contact
number of our marketing manager's
personal so along the way if the
participants are having any queries you
can reach out to us at any point of time
so does anyone have any further queries
if so please let us know in the chat
and if anyone is left to share their
email IDs please uh share that as well
thank you uh we'll be emailing out to
you
okay I'll pass for a couple of seconds
so that the participants who are yet to
share the email IDs they can share it
and be ending the meeting
thank you so much everyone
thank you everyone
hello
yes
uh yeah ma'am actually I had to ask that
if we have some specific project that we
want to do and be mentored by the mentor
at your end so is it possible to do that
so a doctor and shubham could you please
take up that query
yeah like uh if you have your own
particular research question then
definitely uh you can discuss with the
mentor and you can proceed with the
research part
thank you so much so uh Whom Shall I
contact or what email ID I shall contact
for this uh you can like contact us at
um
[Music]
then we will connect with you with one
of our project manager or video
okay sure thank you so much
thank you so much of them
anyone is left to share please share
your email IDs and I'll be ending the
meeting
all right I guess everyone has shared so
uh with that thank you everyone for
joining today's webinar and we hope to
see you all for the program session one
as well so thank you everyone have a
great day